for today's classic interview we're
going back to my interview in October of
2014 with Bill bowring and I don't think
I really have to explain the relevance
of this interview to you this interview
was about how did Putin's Russia become
Putin's Russia and we talked about a lot
of aspects of Vladimir Putin's past and
and most recent escapades and I think
it's particularly interesting given what
we now know about Vladimir Putin that we
didn't know in October of 2014 to
re-watch this interview so we'll get
right into it my interview with Bill
bowring from 2014
how did Vladimir Putin's Russia become
what it is I'm joined today by Professor
bill bowring who is professor of law at
the Birkbeck University of London also
author of law rights and ideology in
Russia landmarks in the destiny of a
great power it's really great to have
you on and I think a lot of our audience
is very aware of the last two to four to
maybe 10 years of history in Russia
there of course following as we are some
of the moves that have been made by
Vladimir Putin but most people don't
have a sense of how going all the way
back several hundred years what we're
seeing today in Russia connects to an
ideology and a framework from from years
past so let's start laying it out as
broadly as possible what was the
catalyst as you may call it that set
Russia on the path which we're now
observing well I'd like to go back to
the 16th century
when you had Ivan the Terrible Ivan the
fourth in Moscow and Queen Elizabeth the
first in England and actually that's
when you have the beginning of Russia
muscular men rustling as a great
continental Empire and the beginning of
England as a worldwide maritime and
brand that was really English defeat of
the Spanish and what a lot of people
don't know is that Ivan the Terrible
proposed marriage to
the verse and she told him to get lost
but something which I often stress is
that England and Russia have been on the
same side of practically every war with
the exception of the Crimean War and in
fact the two empires grew in a way which
didn't really need to confident because
Russia was spreading across the Eurasian
continent Britain was spreading around
the world through sea power and both
Russia and Britain are suffering at the
present moment from a deep psychological
trauma which is the loss of empire in
the really quite recent class and is
that what you feel is today a great
driver or catalyst for the more you know
we have these kind of conflicting sides
within Russia right there's the
westernizers and as we saw that was
certainly a big issue in the conflict
with Ukraine and involving Crimea and
then you have those who are more kind of
the slava files or the the the II I
don't know what other term there may be
but for a long time there have been
these two camps have there not well I
would say the ideology of the present
regime in Russia the ideology is that
what unites Putin and the people around
him is that they want Russia to be a
great power and to be recognized and
respected out at around the world so I
would say the Russian leadership see the
world in geopolitical terms and
therefore the interpretation of what's
been happening in Ukraine from the
Russian regime point of view is the
rutter is encircled by the United States
and its allies and Ukraine was really a
step too far for the for NATO in
particular so I think that that's not
the only factor but I think that
explains quite a bit of the way that the
Russian regime has been acting I find it
very interesting that with some
countries there is a kind of less
circuitous history with regard to the
direction that the country has gone in
then Russia and if you look I mean of
course we have in world war two Russia's
influence with the Allies and we know
about that but even going back further
during the 1860s we saw the abolition of
serfdom we saw the introduction of the
jury trial I mean these were reforms
that we saw in Russia that may not
necessarily always be associated with
the the kind of public face of Vladimir
Putin today I think it's an extremely
important and actually brought the
alexander ii abolished serfdom in 1861
several years before the United States
supports slavery and why did he do that
which was a massive step it was because
Russia had being defeated in the Crimean
War by Britain and France and that was
just a huge shock because after the
defeat of Napoleon we tend to forget
that the Russian army marched all the
way to Paris defeating Napoleon on the
way so after 1812 they arrived in Paris
in 1814 Master Paris in extremely good
order and went home again having done
the job so Russia after 1814 thought it
was invincible and then to lose the
Crimean War
not very many years later that was a
massive shock and so we had the huge
legal reforms in in fact jury trial
introduced in 1864 throughout the whole
of the Russian Empire that continued
right up until 1917 and one of the big
steps in Russia since the collapse of
the Soviet Union has been the
reintroduction of jury trial throughout
Russia and we also tend to forget that
Putin in the first three years that he
was president so up until he arrested
mr. Khodorkovsky in 2003 and he actually
cited the great legal reformers of the
19th century and presented himself as
being the heir of alexander ii so and
that went into reverse the other side of
course of what Putin was doing between
2000 and 2003 was the second chechen war
which was absolutely vicious but within
Russia itself
there were very serious legal reforms
including the reintroduction of jury
trial what do you think is mostly
responsible if it's even possible to sum
things up I mean of course there's so
many facets to this but how would you
characterize the primary catalyst for
what we've seen happen within Russia
over the last six to eight to ten years
do you think that this is an issue of a
desire to maintain this kind of
caricature of Russian sovereignty which
clearly has been an important thing at
least in kind of this theoretical way -
Vladimir Putin or how would you assess
the the catalyzing factors for the
recent decade or so of Russian policy
well I would say the key factor is that
Russia and China of course - many
Russians look at China very closely
following very different paths so Russia
went for
really dismantling the Soviet system
with a wholesale attack on the Communist
Party in the early years of Boris
Yeltsin really as the person before
liberalizing the economy whereas of
course China went the other way and kept
the iron control of the Communist Party
as the basis for liberalizing the
economy so very different parts and of
course in Russia during the 1990s there
was absolute chaos with a president who
was drinking a quart of vodka every day
and was frequently drunk in public so
people look back at that kind of wild
period of the 1990s with horror so a lot
of the secret of Putin has been but you
have a an individual who is so growing
who presents himself as being a strong
man who's a black belt in judo and of
course he has been very fortunate
because up until very recently we've had
very high oil prices and that that has
actually funded a situation in Russia
where of course a few people get
ridiculously rich but everybody has
become better off and people who have
actually been paid on time until this
year when oil prices of course have gone
through the flow
and once again in Russia there's a very
serious situation like I just say a word
about ideology here yeah which is that
you mentioned sovereignty very very
important so if you want to know what is
the ideological slogan as it were of the
regime it is sovereignty and sovereign
democracy this is the invention of a
chap called sir Cobb who is very he's a
younger generation very much the
audiologist of the regime and in 2006 a
book was published called sovereignties
sovereign legette edited by one of the
group of Young Conservatives Iran Putin
and with chapters by Putin Medvedev sort
of edited by young conservative called
Carozza and the these theoretical center
of this book bizarrely is the thought of
the Nazi legal theorist Carl Schmitt and
the central chapter is by the leading
Russian expose on Carl Schmitt he
translates his work from German into
Russian called sovereignty as a
political choice there you are I think
that is right at the centre of the
thinking of the regime in Russia at the
moment well and it's fascinating because
in a place as different from the United
States as Russia you still see this
caricature of sovereignty and this
calling card of sovereignty being used
in a way that is not that different as
we've seen here in the US groups like
the tea party and a narco libertarian
groups co-opting this concept of
sovereignty also for their own political
gain and while the groups could not be
more different than than the political
forces in Russia you can't help but see
the similarity there well I think it's
very interesting because some of those
people really admire what Putin is
trading of the moment they do that's
actually interesting they do it very
yeah and that's because of his very
pronounced conservative terms since 2012
and what I find very interesting is that
Madrid oh of course during his four
years as president he was
some of the under the control of Putin
nonetheless introduced some liberal
reforms and brought some liberals into
government and since Putin came back in
2012 all of that is being dismantled
mostly has been dismantled and the
people made better brought in have been
got riddled there's only one left is the
Minister of Justice mr. Khanna valid
really this is a whole series of things
but amongst them of course social
conservatism so on the question of the
attitudes walls homosexuals and gays LVT
i cetera putin has taken a radically
conservative turn which is welcomed by
many conservatives in Europe and the
United States no question about it we've
been speaking with professor Bill
bowring the book is law rights and
ideology and Russia landmarks in the
destiny of a great power really great to
have you on thank you so much I'm so
eager thank you